У відносинах між Угорщиною та Україною багато конфліктних питань.
Минулого тижня ваш прем'єр Віктор Орбан заявив, що
не бачить жодного шансу домовитись з Україною,
що в Києві сприйняли як втручання у внутрішні справи.
Що ваш прем'єр мав на увазі?
І чому він зробив таку заяву перед початком передвиборчої кампанії в Україні?
Знаєте, ми згадали події останнього року,
які стосувалися співпраці з нашою сусідкою Україною.
Ми згадали це станом на минулий вересень, коли ухвалили закон про освіту.
Коли ще раніше я заводив про це мову
зі співрозмовниками та колегами з України, мені завжди казали:
ні, в такому вигляді закон не ухвалять.
Але це сталося через кілька днів після набуття
чинності Угоди про асоціацію між ЄС та Україною,
щодо якої ми надали нашим українським колегам велетенську підтримку, бо вважали,
що ЄС нечесно поводився з Україною в питаннях
безвізового режиму та імплементації асоціації.
Тож ми підтримували Україну багатьма способами.
Це було наче ніж у спину, коли, попри попередні обіцянки,
такий закон про мови прийняли.
На додачу до цього у першому читанні в Раді
був проголосований новий закон щодо застосування мов меншин.
Він просто уб'є можливість використовувати
мови меншин у державному управлінні, у ЗМІ та культурі.
Плюс "Миротворець" склав список з угорцями,
журналістами, міністром закордонних справ, угорцями, які живуть в Україні,
- і їх оголосили ворогами України. Зареєстрували
петицію для збору підписів за депортацію угорців із Закарпаття.
Знаєте, у ХХІ столітті висувати такі пропозиції неприйнятно.
Офіс культурного центру угорців в Ужгородні двічі підривали, вдруге він горів.
Усі ці події дуже чітко дають нам зрозуміти, що попри наші зусилля, попри той факт,
що ми постачаємо газ Україні, що ми запрошуємо
відпочивати в Угорщині тисячі українських дітей,
чиї батькі воюють на Сході, але коли йдеться
про права нашої меншини, то все рухається в негативному напрямку.
Тому очевидно, що, з огляду на наш досвід, ми не можемо очікувати прогресу.
Тож якщо Україна зробить ті три речі, які ви назвали
щодо закону про освіту, цю частину конфлікту буде вичерпано?
Так, цілком. Але тут нема нічого нового. Насправді
нас шокує, коли ці питання видають за щось нове.
Ми вже рік говорим про них, із минулого листопада. Але безрезультатно.
З приводу закону про освіту Україна мала суперечки
і з іншими країнами, наприклад, із Румунією.
Але з іншими країнами ці питання вирішуються.
Лише не з Угорщиною.
Ви самі в курсі, що це неправда. Запитайте румунів,
запитайте міністра освіти Румунії чи запитайте
міністра закордонних справ Румунії. Неправда, що все було вирішено.
- Тож це не було вирішено?
- Ні, не було.
А заява Орбана? Чи є вона втручанням
у передвиборчу кампанію в Україні?
Ні, точно не є, бо вона стосувалася
двосторонніх відносин між Україною і Угорщиною.
Питання порушення прав національних меншин, зокрема угорців,
є питанням, в яких і ми маємо право голосу.
Це не лише двостороннє питання, вони ще й багатостороннє.
Адже про права меншин йдеться не лише у двосторонніх угодах між Україною та Угорщиною,
але також і в міжнародному праві.
Не кажучи вже про той факт, що у своїй
річній національній програмі спрівпраці з НАТО
Україна зобов'язалася постійно покращувати рівень дотримання прав меншин.
Додайте до цього європейські правила та стандарти, які теж порушуються.
Тож ми зацікавлені у дружніх відносинах.
Ми це довели.
Ви кажете про дружні відносини. Але ж ви блокуєте
Комісії Україна-НАТО на політичному рівні.
І в вересні ви сказали, що будете блокувати
ще й євроінтеграцію України. Чи будете ви створювати нові перешкоди?
Ви маєте бути справедливими та точними, а також
вказувати послідовність подій.
Тому що це не ми наклали вето, а потім Україна ухвалила закон про мови.
Ні, спершу український парламент проголосував
за порушення права етнічних угорців.
Очевидно, що ми були змушені відреагувати.
Хоча були б найщасливішими у світі,
якби цього не сталося.
Угорщина дала чітко зрозуміти: якщо Україна
повернеться на той шлях, яким вона йшла раніше
щодо прав меншин, то ми будемо першими,
хто повернеться до нашої попередньої політики підтримки України.
Бо якщо у вас є країна-сусідка, то ви хочете
мати з нею хороші відносини,
особливо якщо брати до уваги 150 тисяч
етнічних угорців, які живуть у вашої сусідки.
Тому ми і запустили програми економічного розвитку.
Тому ми й допомагали Україні, коли йшлося
про євро- та євроатлантичну інтеграцію.
Але після рішення занести угорців до "чорних списків"
та почати збирати підписи за депортацію угорців
із Закарпаття це неприйнятно.
Щодо етнічних угорців на Закарпатті.
Видавання угорських паспортів громадянам України
стало одним із конфліктних моментів.
Для чого Угорщина видає угорське громадянство українцям?
Так, звісно. Подвійне громадянство - це феномен,
який існує в усій Європі та визнається по всій Європі.
Є інші країни-сусідки України, такі як Румунія,
в яких законодавство дозволяє подвійне громадянство.
У міжнародному праві чітко прописано,
хто має право на подвійне громадянство.
І на Закарпатті живуть угорці, які,
згідно з угорським законодавством,
мають право на подвійне громадянство...
Але в Конституції України йдеться про принцип єдиного громадянства.
Але якщо ви поглянете на українські закони,
то там ніде не сказано, що мати паспорт іншої країни - це злочин чи це заборонено.
Зараз у Верховній Раді зареєстрували законопроект,
який запроваджує таке покарання, але поки що його немає,
бо інакше не було б потреби в цьому новому законі.
Тож усе, що ми робили, повністю відповідало
угорським нормам, міжнародним і європейським нормам,
і не суперечило та не передбачає покарання
жодним законом України. Тому я справді
не зрозумів, чому виник такий скандал.
У той же час є закон, який забороняє чиновникам мати громадянство іншої країни.
Скажіть, чи давали ви громадянство Угорщини українським держслужбовцям?
Чесно кажучи, не знаю. Але що точно відомо, то...
В Угорщині для отримання другого громадянства
неважливо, є людина чиновником чи ні.
Тому я не знаю.
Інша тема - це відносини ЄС із Росією.
Таке враження, що уряд Угорщини зайняв значно м'якшу позицію щодо Росії.
Наприклад, критикує санкції. Або ж один із перших візитів Путіна до ЄС
після анексії Криму та Мінських угод був саме до Угорщини.
Чи намагається ваш уряд здобути якусь ласку від Путіна?
Дуже нечесно, як ЗМІ намагаються представити цю тему, зокрема і ви.
Бо ви натякаєте на речі, які просто не відповідають дійсності.
Чи запитаєте ви німців, чому вони ведуть бізнес з Росією у величезних масштабах?
Чи питаєте ви найбільші західноєвропейські енергетичні компанії,
чому вони спільно з "Газпромом" будують "Північний потік-2",
який стане найбільшою інвестицією в енергетичну інфраструктуру в історії ЄС?
Чи запитуєте французів, чому французький президент Макрон
став зірковим гостем на Петербурзькому
економічному форумі на сцені разом із президентом Путіним?
Яка ваша думка щодо того, що на Російському енергетичному тижні
Путін вийшов на сцену разом із головами правління
чотирьох найбільших західноєвропейських енергетичних концернів?
А те, що цього року Макрон 12 разів розмовляв із Путіним,
канцлер Австрії чотири рази зустрічався з Путіним,
а за останні три роки відбулося 15
російсько-німецьких зустрічей на найвищому рівні?
Країни Західної Європи роблять величезний бізнес із Росією.
А ми - маленька центральноєвропейська країна -
лише просимо рівних правил гри.
Дуже несправедливо, що Західна Європа отримає новий трубопровід
до західної частини континенту та феноменально
посилить своєю енергетичну безпеку,
але разом із тим убиває всі спроби Центральної Європи отримати те саме.
Це подвійні стандарти. На поверхні ми бачимо
словесне протистояння, а під килимом вони роблять
величезний бізнес. Чи запитали б ви про це західних європейців?
Тоді скажіть, як би ви змінили політику Євросоюзу щодо Росії?
Єдине, чого ми просимо, - чесного і критичного аналізу.
Ми запровадили санкції кілька років тому
і маємо чітко визначені цілі, прив'язані до санкцій.
Думаю, прохання чесного критичного аналізу того,
чи виявилася успішною така політика,
є абсолютно виправданим.
Це усе, про що ми просимо, проте цього не сталося.
Ми завжди утримувалися від будь-яких вето
щодо санкцій і ніколи не порушували єдності ЄС.
З іншого боку, на відміну від Західної Європи,
ми не будуємо великих трубопроводів з росіянами.
Думаю, справедливість надзвичайно важлива.
Дуже просто поширювати брехню про маленьку центральноєвропейську країну
на користь великих країн Західної Європи та приховувати,
наскільки активно вони самі співпрацюють з Росією. Це просто нечесно.
Тож жодного скасування санкцій без виконання мінських домовленостей перед цим?
Цілком очевидно, які цілі ми прив'язали до санкцій щодо Росії,
але досі не було можливості оцінити,
наскільки ми просунулися до цих цілей.
Очевидно, важливо, щоб мінські домовленості виконували обидві сторони,
що сприятиме безпеці та стабільності усього регіону.
Значно краще мати в регіоні хороші відносини,
аніж погані. Це було б краще і для України.